[Music]
this episode and others like it are made
possible by the generous support of my
patrons on patreon
if you'd like to help support my channel
and get early access to every video
consider becoming a patron at
patreon.com second thought
the first important thing you can do is
to be sure you know what communism
really is
in other words know your enemy whoever
you are
wherever you are discuss the red menace
with your neighbors your friends your
business associates your fellow students
are you a factory worker a member of a
union a trade association a service club
or a church
be alert to spot anyone promoting the
communist line
and be doubly alert when the communists
start hunting you that's right no matter
who you are
you have your own circle of influence so
the commies want you
they have a variety of approaches any
one of them may sound reasonable even
commendable
just don't ever agree to join any
committee
or support any cause or sign any
petition
or allow your name to be used in any
manner
until you know the whole story who's
behind it
what their real objectives are i feel
the millions of americans have long
voted the democrat ticket
are just as loyal they love america just
as much they hate communism just as much
as the average republican which which
proves my contention that is that in
this fight against communism
it isn't a democrat fight it isn't a
republican fight it's so easy you see to
talk about communism generally to talk
about the sellout in
china and korea generally but unless you
call the role of the traitors
treason isn't like little topsy it
doesn't just grow it's created by men
with
faces and men with names i think those
of us who have been elected by the
american people
to man the watchtowers unless we have
the intelligence
to recognize the traitors and then if i
may use a
word which we use in wisconsin unless we
have the guts
to name them we should be taken down
from those watchtowers and should not be
representing the american people and i
don't intend to
ever avoid giving the names of traitors
giving the names of communists
and i discover them an important
position
in last week's video i mentioned polling
that indicated only half of american
young people hold a positive opinion of
capitalism
it shouldn't be surprising to anyone
that we're beginning to see a
predictably paranoid response from the
reactionary crowd
if you thought mccarthyism was a thing
of the past well
no such luck in this episode we're going
to talk about a budding effort to
enforce so-called patriotic education
standards in american schools
and what that means for the nation and
the world going forward
okay let's set the stage this past month
florida governor ron desantis held a
bill signing event where he
and some others explained what exactly
their program entails
i'm going to play a few clips to give
you a sense of what we're dealing with
and then we'll talk about some specifics
the bill also expands our previous
efforts in civics
to add a requirement for the high school
government class
that students receive instruction on the
evils of communism
and totalitarian ideologies we have
a number of people in in florida
particularly southern florida
who've escaped totalitarian regimes
who've escaped communist dictatorships
to be able to come to america we want
all students to understand
the difference why would somebody flee
across
water say leaving from cuba to come to
southern florida
why would somebody leave a place like
vietnam
why would people leave these countries
and risk their life to be able to come
here it's important that students
understand that
okay lots to unpack here house bill 5
which is one of three related bills
includes a requirement that high school
students be taught about quote the evils
of communism and totalitarian ideologies
desantis then mentions cuba and vietnam
let's start with cuba
cuba is an island nation which has
suffered under brutal u.s sanctions for
nearly 60 years now
these sanctions have been denounced by
the un as illegal and inhumane
and every single member state with the
exception of the us and israel
continues to vote against the oppressive
measures measures which have cost the
cuban economy
trillions of dollars despite this
cruelty cuba is a country with a greater
life expectancy than the u.s
they had a better kovid response than
the u.s and the basic human decency to
send their doctors around the world to
places that needed help
without any expectation of financial
gain why would somebody flee across
shark-infested waters to come to america
i don't know ron
maybe it's because decades of illegal
u.s embargoes are slowly strangling an
innocent nation
a nation which deserves like any other
the freedom to determine their own
future
the united states will not allow that
it's no surprise that some cubans have
emigrated to the nearest country
what about vietnam honestly i'm not sure
what desantis is talking about here
he makes it sound like there's some
massive exodus from vietnam to the u.s
that is not the case the vietnamese show
overwhelming support for their
government which isn't surprising
considering how effectively that
government handles crises like kovid and
actually takes care of their citizens in
fact out of 45 polled nations
vietnam reported the highest rate of
satisfaction with their government's
response to the coronavirus pandemic
going back to cuba as more free market
policies have been implemented over the
years
cuban satisfaction with their government
has declined dropping from 81 percent
under fidel castro to 54
today the us congress by contrast enjoys
an abysmal 26
approval rating that is among the worst
in the world
and frankly it's not surprising both
democrats and republicans have shown
time and again that they don't care
about the american people
they only care about their corporate
donations that's why we had the worst
coveted response in the world
it's why we're the only industrialized
nation not to have some form of
universal health care
it's why our life expectancy is on the
decline why rates of depression and
suicide are on the rise
and why a full half of young americans
have lost faith in capitalism entirely
and if we're talking about americans in
vietnam vietnam is constantly among the
top foreign retirement destinations for
americans
so there is population exchange between
vietnam and the u.s
it's just not in the direction desantis
would have you believe
now as part of this bill florida will
create a portrait and patriotism library
so students can learn about real
patriots who came to this country
after seeing the horrors of these
communist regimes we actually have
folks here today you'll hear from her in
a minute
anna abauza she came to the united
states when she was a teenager
fleeing from nicaragua when the
sandinistas brought socialism to that
country
another part of the bill is the creation
of what florida is calling the portraits
in patriotism library
where students can learn about people
who are willing to be useful pawns to
the political right and condemn
left-wing politics
including one person who fled from
nicaragua when quote the sandinistas
brought socialism to that country
if ron desantis weren't perhaps the
dumbest politician currently living
i would assume this was satire the years
he's referring to
are widely known as the period during
which the united states funded
right-wing death squads in nicaragua and
el salvador
and it wasn't just indirect funding the
cia
also played an active and criminal role
in what were called the dirty wars
for example they planted mines around
three nicaraguan harbors
which constituted an act of state
terrorism
while the mining of nicaraguan harbors
has caused a huge political furor in the
united states
anti-sandinista guerrilla sources here
in costa rica
feel vindicated because of the tactical
effectiveness of the mining
specifically the denial of these
high-speed patrol boats and landing
craft
to the communist government in nicaragua
thankfully
the u.s was convicted of violating
international law at the world court
so when desantis talks about people
fleeing nicaragua when socialism came to
the country
what he's leaving out is that socialism
was on track to improve people's lives
and counter the lie of capitalist
superiority
so the united states decided to
intervene and plunge the country into
chaos through unspeakable violence and
violations of international law
none of this is secret knowledge you can
go online right now and read about
reagan's meddling in the global south
as always i've left some links in the
description
finally i'm signing house bill 233
the bill requires colleges and
universities to conduct annual
assessments
on the intellectual freedom and
viewpoint diversity
at these institutions it used to be
thought
that a university campus was a place
where you'd be exposed to a lot of
different ideas
unfortunately now the norm is really
these are more intellectually repressive
environments
you have orthodoxies that are promoted
uh and other viewpoints are
shunned or even suppressed we don't want
that
in florida you need to have a true
contest of ideas
students should not be shielded from
from ideas and we want robust first
amendment speech
on our college and university campuses
and i think that
having intellectual diversity is
something that's very very important
okay house bill 233 quote requires
public colleges and universities to
conduct annual assessments on the
intellectual
freedom and viewpoint diversity at these
institutions
ron desantis is all about intellectual
freedom college kids having the chance
to learn dissenting opinions
and freedom of speech on campus except
you know when he's actively trying to
ban things like critical race theory
which isn't even taught in florida or an
accurate history of the slave trade
topics which don't comply with his
vision of a staunchly right-wing
education
let's get one thing straight
reactionaries like desantis
and their wealthy suburban supporters
seem to believe that all colleges and
universities are anti-capitalist
indoctrination centers
to put it as gently as i possibly can
that is among the dumbest things i have
ever heard
to my knowledge there is not a single
school in this country that doesn't
allow college republican groups
or college democrat groups both the
republicans
and the democrats are capitalist parties
even the most supposedly left-wing
candidates like elizabeth warren go out
of their way to remind people that
they're capitalists
you know what's often not allowed on
college campuses socialist groups
the ideology desantis claims is
brainwashing all our students
they're often seen as extremists and
faculty don't want to risk their jobs by
associating with actual left-wing ideas
for those of you who have attended
college leave in the comments if you
ever met an even remotely socialist
professor
i will be very surprised in my
experience
and the experience of everyone i've
spoken to capitalist economics and ideas
are the norm on college campuses
are you a student or a teacher well
write to your congressman for a copy of
j
edgar hoover's report communist target
youth see how on direct orders from
moscow
the party is in a drive to get communist
speakers
into our colleges and universities
taking advantage of american academic
freedom
and the students naturally inquiring
minds
their aim is to preach revolutionary
tactics and change
peaceful campuses into scenes like this
the communist incited student riots in
san francisco
the assertion that communists are
brainwashing the country's college
students
isn't new it's a page ripped directly
from mccarthyism
and we need to understand it as such it
is part of the new red scare
and we thought what if we could do that
same thing for people who fled to
america who had
all the places in the world to choose to
come but they chose to come here to the
united states
because where they were from freedom was
a luxury and liberty was just a dream
what if we could interview those people
and have young folks like those that are
here today
ask them questions and hear back about
what it really means
to live in a communist regime like that
in cuba
or to other totalitarian regimes like in
nicaragua or venezuela
and that's what that's what today is all
about and myself and representative zika
the members
that are here today gathered with the
victims of communism months ago
on the steps of the capitol to make sure
that we would achieve just that
want to know a fun fact about the
victims of communism memorial foundation
they count people who died from kovid
and literal nazi soldiers from world war
ii
as victims of communism i mean yeah
technically it was the soviets who beat
the nazis
which is an odd thing for the foundation
to admit because people like desantis
and other american politicians love to
claim it was the u.s that beat them
as far as kovid deaths go the
hyper-capitalist u.s
has had the most deaths by far and
socialist and communist countries have
had among the fewest
that should tell you all you need to
know about the victims of communism
foundation
it's a disgusting disingenuous
capitalist propaganda outlet that
dishonors the memory of those it claims
to remember
what this legislation hopes to achieve
besides fully rewriting actual history
is to have guest lecturers from
blatantly anti-communist front groups
come to schools and
inject mccarthy-era cold war rhetoric
into the minds of american students
starting them on the track to become
obedient terrified little worker drones
when they complete their state-mandated
propaganda education
i can say i agree with desantis on one
thing
teaching american history is critical
that's why i am
so opposed to this new initiative it
doesn't teach history
it dredges up the worst aspect of the
red scare and tries to indoctrinate
children with bizarre
outdated and flat-out false pro-america
anti-communist propaganda
at the end of the day socialists like me
aren't asking for much
we think it's important to have an
honest reckoning of america's role in
world history
the good and the bad we shouldn't just
leave out the parts that reflect poorly
on the world's most powerful nation
we should be able to confront difficult
history and say you know what
yeah that was wrong and work to correct
it we should be able to soberly assess
the failures of our current economic
system and be willing to try new ideas
but unfortunately i don't see that
happening anytime soon
we seem to be experiencing the first
wave of extreme reaction to capitalism's
decline
it's staunchest offenders circling the
wagons around a fake mythos
launching actual indoctrination
campaigns and attempting to reignite the
red scare
a period widely considered as one of the
most misguided
dystopian and un-american in history
on the bright side this whole campaign
is reminiscent of dare
which i'm sure people my age remember
from their time in school
the idea was to teach kids that drugs
were literally going to kill you
immediately
and that they made you a bad person
unsurprisingly
that approach didn't work and it got
otherwise apathetic kids interested in
drugs
that's just how kids are they love to do
the things grown-ups say are bad
so in this case if we're lucky in a few
years we'll have middle schoolers in
florida handing out bootleg copies of
the state and revolution at recess
it's funny to think about but in all
seriousness this kind of reactionary
legislation is a big problem
it indicates a severe rightward shift in
american politics
and i think there's more on the way the
american people need to decide what they
stand for
is it a historical and xenophobic fairy
tales about an america that never
existed
or is it the belief that all humans are
created equal
that economic ideas are meant to be
challenged and that progress does not
have to be at the expense of human life
and dignity
capitalism leads us down the former road
i think we should choose the latter
i mentioned at the beginning of this
video that this kind of content is made
possible by my patrons on patreon
when i decided to make the shift from
general interest stuff to more radical
political content
i knew i ran the risk of syncing my
channel and losing my ad revenue and
sponsors
these days it's pretty hard to get a
sponsor on my videos
i have one reliable one and they're
great but for the most part i'm having
to rely on the generous support of
viewers like you
if you appreciate the work i'm doing and
you're able to chip in even a dollar a
month
i would greatly appreciate the support
as a little show of that appreciation
every patron regardless of donation
amount gets early access to every video
as well as access to our patrons only
discord server it's a great place to
hang out
chat with other like-minded people or
learn about socialist theory in our book
club
i'm also pretty active in the server so
you're always welcome to ping me to ask
a question or just say hi
you can find my patreon join our growing
discord server and get early access to
every video at patreon.com
second thought if you enjoyed this video
consider dropping a like
if you hated it a thumbs down you can
check out my previous videos by clicking
the links on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week
[Music]
you